oh yes it's good to be back in the
studio with the greatest running back in
Eagles history Brian Westbrook how you
feeling I feel a good I've called you B
West my entire life have you in fact I
remember one time I was at a bar in
Chicago and I was watching the game and
I yelled out get the [ __ ] go be West and
some Chicago guy was like be West what
nickname is that I was like shut the
[ __ ] up right it's what I call B doc B
West and J trot listen
Philly is not just Philly but a lot of
people love the nickname everybody loves
nickname Jerry yeah I want to shorten
everything yeah I get less yeah of
course laughs that makes sense okay Beco
Aiko Aiko Aiko I just got back from
Oakland flew out after our show on
Monday I don't know how you did it come
on man we got to do what I don't know
how you're awake right now know it
either I don't know either
drinking coffee we got luckily honey in
hot water trying to I've decided I'm not
gonna talk from Thursday night to Sunday
morning I realized that I was yelling so
much during Sunday football at like Josh
Allen yeah like you're [ __ ] me right
now
I lost my voice there will be a lot of
people happy that you're not talking
from Thursday to Sunday a lot of people
that was to take a little shot early do
you like the picture uh behind your left
shoulder this is put that in there I
love that he put this in here now fro
Donovan McNabb gotta check it out this
is one of his worst looks but this is
hilarious to see Don with this the Afro
and I'm ready yet the braids he had it
all going on yeah I told Nick as long as
you put a new picture in there every
every wedding so it'll be good so I'm in
Oakland doing the shooting the final
episode for ditch the playbook and it
went really really well by the way if
you haven't seen the Sean McVeigh one
yet please get on to Twitter let's do it
again
Sean McVeigh
I showed him literally videos from when
he was 17 years old so 16 years ago and
I would show on the beginning of a play
and I'd say what happens and he goes oh
that's 876 Trail flood rollout right
50-yard bomb it's awesome go to Twitter
- what you guys did last week retweet it
with this episode is so good that and I
will retweet all of the best responses I
came in here Matthew Barry's retweeting
it we pick up some traction it's the
white book hashtag D the P coming in
strong quick Sean McVeigh story I'm in
the indie for the combine two years ago
okay we're in the bar me and my boys are
chilling this really it's like a whole
party scene there
I have India's list it's it's Spring
Break for NFL coach that's what that is
and so I'm there we hanging out at the
bar and I see Sean McVeigh walk in he
looks just like average dude he does
just as this guy walking he popping in
and he stops oh my god Brian Westbrook
he's this is awkward
oh my god Brian Westbrook I admire your
game so much and he went down all the
plays I love when you come out of the
back but we're trying to get you
one-on-one with the linebacker we're in
the bar I'm I'm drinking he's like this
all you have to do is we do this and we
do that and we're trying to get Gurley
to do this we're trying to get Gurley
just talking about certain aspects of
your game yes that he studied to try and
implement into his own exactly which is
crazy now this it has to be midnight at
this time yes everyone's drinking
everyone's having a good time probably
except for Sean McVeigh cuz he's not
even 21 yet he's just chillin they're
hanging out he wants to talk game plan
with that's how much of a football nerd
he is yeah and you were have to respect
it I love it at the same point you want
to be like Sean relax they don't know
that no he doesn't get there there's not
code there these young coaches they're
about football football football that's
it now but Andy is such a brilliant mind
but I feel like he would look at you and
be like you want it you want one of my
ribs yeah Andy if there is food involved
Andy is never had a big meal with Andy
Reid no you've never I promise you that
I was around Andy for eight years there
was maybe one time that I saw him eat
anything other than a salad maybe once
stop yep every is not real every
Saturday I promise you every Saturday
night the last thing he would say to the
team is and I'll
I you a cheeseburger we would go lead
the team meeting go downstairs and his
food more food that you can imagine and
he was sit at the table with his coaches
and he really eat a salad that's it one
salad and I don't know what he would he
did when he left but at that tea meal he
would eat a salad that's it Wow was a
salad with a pizza on top I'm not making
funny it's all out of love but so would
you guys wonder like where is he what
else is he I think that the common
thought is like okay Andy's going
upstairs and ordering everything on the
menu for room service I mean there
listen I'm a realist I understand I
understand my own weight and I go up and
down oh yeah when I eat crazy I gain
weight when I when I when I when I don't
I lose weight and so I have to believe
for him to maintain that stature he's
eating he's eating some way I'd like
your half of rack of baby rib salad
please thank you
the only thing that sucked about ditch
the playbook was our last episode it's
gonna be coming out later this year was
with our favorite rookie Johnathan Abram
yeah and yesterday I also had to report
the news that he's gonna be out for the
season torn labrum torn rotator cuff
goes out there in the first quarter or
excuse me in the beginning of the second
quarter
Deshawn Hamilton's catching the ball on
the sideline about to get a second foot
down Abram does what Abram does launches
himself like a missile hit some second
foot never comes down Denver's got a
punt beautiful play problem is when he
landed all that happened showed and then
he played the other three quarter or the
other two quarters on adrenaline like a
grown man didn't get shot up like a
warrior he I heard per source bad at
this
I heard per source that his arm kept
getting like more more sore during the
game
so in between plays a cornerback would
come over and shake it yeah to kind of
loosen it up a per source when he hit
the ground
per thought okay keep going listen a
good his shoulder pops out and he gets
up and her source takes a deep breath
and
shoulder goes back into place yeah and
then in between every play he had a
quarterback just shaking his arm out so
that he can go and and knock people
purse or well this is per source the
truth it's shocking that he's able to
play without being shot up I mean I
would he try to ask you for references
I'll tell you this towards the latter
part of my career I was getting shot up
before the game just to just neutralize
what was gonna go on during the game I
can't even imagine I remember I broke my
ribs in the middle of the Washington
game I don't know Oh 607 and I played a
little bit and then at some point the
pain is like all right yeah this is too
much so you go in there you get shot up
you come back out and you feel like a
needle oh it's long so told so there
long needles first of all they're long
and they're thick and you've gotten in
it's not an easy process and not do they
just shoot it right where it hurts
no so before the game they shoot you in
your butt so like they trying to find a
muscular my good this is the hole
numbing agent this is a treacherous what
is it called tortor all tore it all tore
it all yeah yeah yeah and that's the
only thing they even use it anymore I
hope that's like the I can run through a
brick wall and not feel anything I came
into the league and the vets would
always tell me yeah you probably don't
need it yet you probably don't need it
yet and they all of them would get shot
up before the game
really it's just a high-powered
anti-inflammatory just a little bit of
swelling changes everything in you so
it's a high-power anti-inflammatory and
it just makes you feel new takes you
from 75 percent to 100 I'm shocked that
he didn't take one shot that's who he is
he's a grown man that's what that means
is and then he after he still shot with
us for two hours was so nice to the
entire crew they end up Duke took tup
some fans was the ticket stand up man he
is he is my favorite rookie he is a 33
percent rookie so please get into his
mentions and wish him well I knew that
one of the big things on his list was
Defensive Rookie of the Year mhm and he
really believed it the way that they
were gonna use him was gonna allow him
to get five to ten sacks five to ten
picks and he really wanted to go after
to be one of the best young safeties so
I know he's going to be great we're
gonna support him the whole [ __ ] way
because I roll with people that roll
with me and
it sucks it's a breaking that it's it
sucks it's a mindset thing but it guys
like that yeah they just want to play
football
love the gang they have a passion for it
they're gonna do anything they can just
to be able to play they always come back
better yeah they come back better
because they don't want that sense hold
it I said dude you get to be in that
locker room with LaMarcus Joyner and
some people that really know what
they're doing I said let your brain
become a third year guy and then get
your body right so you're gonna sit
there all year and just just be a
monster in the film room dude
Monday Night Football we didn't get a
chance to talk about it Raiders hold off
and beat the Broncos Joe Flacco cool huh
what happened to Joe I mean I asked that
question four years ago yeah if you
can't say what happened so I mean
obviously what happened to John Elway
that he's still able to kind of make
these decisions that are so bad and no
one's could have called him it's not a
talent evaluator he's a good one
apparently but you know you trade for
Joe you figure things didn't work out in
Baltimore maybe he has something left in
the tank no I could have told you that
Brian it's [ __ ] me you should have
called John Elway and told him because
obviously he's delusional because we
didn't see it week one we didn't see it
it looked awful
the Raiders I was very impressed by I
think this Darren Waller is gonna be
bald he's an athlete yeah Josh Jacobs I
love what do you think about Josh Jacobs
mr. running back well here it is
I thought he's gonna be good coming into
the season I think he's a volume back
that's your initial thought big come
from a big squeeze of value backed yeah
but but to me he showed some quickness
that you don't normally see out of some
rookies he shoes don't show some lateral
ability some good vision he has a nice
burst I like that so at the point of
contact he's present in situational
football around the goal line yeah and
I've seen a lot of running backs that
run into their line no no he understands
eeeek level of I can dive into that
crack that's right yeah and listen I I
know John Rooney
he's taking a lot of nonsense crap from
the Antonia Browns deal but I know he
knows how to use running backs yeah he
knows how to get him on space and at
some point during this season they're
gonna say okay we're not gonna run this
guy down into a wall we're just gonna
try to get him in space and use his
athletic ability to for us to
win will you look at that team think
about this Tyrell Williams yeah I
thought he was good when he's with the
charge sure he didn't get a lot of
opportunities a lot of other mouths if
see so many ball teams but he looked
good the other night obviously Waller
looked good the other night most
importantly for that football team dirt
car looked like pre he did leg injury
there how was the best Eric Carr has
looked since that season differently on
a run for MVP different love I'd also
say this about the Raiders Richie
incognito
suspended the first two games he back
he'll be back soon Gabe Jackson their
right guard he's out for like the next
four to five weeks if that offensive
line can get healthy for Trent Brown and
Colton Miller there are two tackles to
make von Miller and Bradley Chubb
practically non-existent Isabel that's a
huge deal for a team that we know that
Jon Gruden is going to be able to pick
some people apart and you have Waller
and you have Tyrell and you have Jacobs
and Hunter Renfro doesn't drop balls no
he makes plays he makes he plays and he
does your taxes better than anyone it's
incredible the big three the big three
for the Raiders
car if he can sustain it yeah big-time
question mark Tyrell Tyrell Josh and
John Jake could be good but Texan Saints
you got a little you got a little spicy
you felt the need to text me yeah oh
Texas yes yes you know that I think that
the Texans are gonna have a down year
yeah but it was it was just doggone
close what did I say the Texans season
was gonna be they're gonna try to get in
shootouts with people it's gonna be all
deshaun Watson they want to win 32 to 30
35 to 33 but their defense is trash
where was JJ Watt where was he yet the
critical moment
critical moment listen that's what
happens when you don't have Jadeveon
Clowney and making double and triple
team you every play right right it's a
huge deal merciless look good
conversation
it looks lenient EJ reader to be a
bigger deal but the problem is is Bill
O'Brien has 100%
running this organization that's the
other thing I told you is that I believe
that Bill O'Brien
the worst situational football coach in
the NFL they need a GM first of all what
did he do on Monday first quarter
Don J Hopkins goes for a first down they
don't get it he calls a timeout and then
he throws the challenge flag I mean they
don't get it and there's two times what
are you doing fourth quarter quick
touchdown - Sean Wasson to take the lead
true Brees thinks and dunks and
everyone's telling me that's Romeo
Crennel you know and that he needs to be
out there around the line which I don't
care if it's Romeo Crennel or Bill
O'Brien that's a coaching staff because
at that point Bill O'Brien is a
defensive coach - yet he's got to go to
Romeo and be like we need to be on these
guys well if you're an offensive coach
you can see it all they had to do was
get to this point yes and they could
kick a 58 yarder and then we can't allow
that and then the one guy that they were
attacking with Ted Ginn across the
middle was this cornerback Erin Colvin
you know they took from the Jaguars last
offseason and they paid him a lot of
money because Erin Colvin was the great
nickel back in between AJ Bowie and
Jalen Ramsay the problem is is maybe he
was great because he was playing between
AJ Buechele and Ramsey worth but what
did they do after the game out of it
caught AJ Bowie and that isn't no
Coleman Colvin excuse me Aaron Colvin if
a coach has the power of a GM that's
what he would do
impulsive and that's what just happened
yeah Bill O'Brien is the GM ran out of
the Texas you know I'm tell you this and
this is and I agree with everything you
just said impulsive decision to cut the
kid that made some mistakes there in the
first game of the season against one of
the Hall of Fame quarterback that's the
whole sense [ __ ] a decision I think
it's you put your put your team in a bad
situation based on your defense I'm
gonna look at the offense side cuz this
is where Bill O'Brien has control yes
when I see my quarterback visit the
medical tent twice in the first half he
got sacked honey 62 times last year like
it crazy - my job getting massages on
the bench in between drives the one
thing that I would have talked to the
Shaun Watson all offseason long similar
case as I've said to Carson wins you're
much more important than a yard you're
much more important to our team than the
first down then a touchdown even you're
much more important to our team in
longevity of our franchise than a win
I'm gonna just tell you that right now
I don't need you diving in the end zone
for touchdowns I don't need you doing
any of these things you're the big
picture of this team yeah but it looked
super it looks yeah it looks great
a loss of her crazy when he's laying on
his back thinking like what am i doing
this is your quarterback
there's your franchise on the mat
drilled so hard on that touchdown throw
to Kenny Stills and to the fact that
after the touchdown the cameras went to
Kenny Stills and then it went to Bill
O'Brien and then it went to deshou
Munson and he was still on the ground
yes and I'll say this about the Shaun
Watson I just love the way it plays ball
though man well I love the way he plays
ball to lady you are right about it let
me add this to your Bill O'Brien rant
yes you give up two first and a second
for Tunsil and still stills play it pays
off son so gave up a couple pressures in
a second he'll get better your
quarterback
by the way still got sacked six times I
know so there's a miscommunication
between routes depth my quarterback
getting the ball out of his hands
protection there's something going on in
that offense but isn't that right that's
been the knock about deshaun Watson for
a long time is because he has the
ability to score a touchdown on every
play yeah he's looking for a touchdown
every play and he tends to hold it long
at the same point I don't he's got a lot
of receivers that are put in to like
beat this guy one-on-one situation yeah
and sometimes those routes take a long
time to develop
but as an offensive coach you say all
offseason the one thing yeah I can't
afford to do is to get this kid killed
yeah true but you have to do a better
job will Lutz unbelievable frickin kick
58 yard field goal mazing but it was it
was such an enjoyable Monday night game
felt really special yeah
and III just like great games like that
I know you hate the Texans that defy
don't hate the Texas kind of feels like
you hate them but they allowed second
but some of the second half of the
football game
I was just alvin kamara show yeah they
allow the the Saints to score on five of
six drives yeah including three straight
touchdowns to open the second half how
do you expect to win like that well you
can't it go well listen there was a stat
that I had and I don't know if I can
pull it up quick enough but part of the
reason why
I am very confident in that Bill O'Brien
is not a great football coach is that
when you look at their record when
they're trailing at halftime or they're
tied which to me it comes down to are
they able to adjust in the last two
years Houston has been tied or trailing
at halftime 17 games what do you think
their record is Brian Westbrook I hope
isn't that open 17 it's not what is it
it's 1 in 61 is it was pretty doggone
close so when you have a head coach that
never improves after the halftime bell
yes but and then you tell me that the
Saints you know they were able so there
are some coaches that can game plan all
week and slow you down the first half
right but the best coaches are the ones
that go in at halftime the Andy Reid's
the Shawn McVeigh is the the the bill OH
bill Bella checks and they go oh I see
what you're doing and now I'm going to
combat it and Bill O'Brien has never
adjusted well I'll tell you this the
good coaches go into halftime and make
the adjustments the best coaches get
their team on the sideline is saying
alright this is what they did last
series this is what we're gonna do the
next series yeah that's what the best
culture right a little bit different
well there it belt lechuck is famous for
right before half writing down all of
the things that he's gonna focus on at
halftime yeah and already telling
assistants to go in there and what to
write on the whiteboard so that they're
gonna fix and that's that's just the
next level you know what's weird because
I remember halftime speeches and I don't
remember any of them I remember going
into halftime my god I'm gonna use it
bathroom I might take my shoulder pads
off I might get retake and then I'm
gonna sit there and look at the coaches
like man I don't care what you say I'm
gonna go out there and just do my job
better next half but if you're telling
me in between series right yes you come
to me you say hey listen you had a
cornerback blitz that you miss or you
run in a zone or they're over playing to
set the edge tell me they're because I
can't remember to think about all that
stuff at halves I can't remember half of
the plays yeah I mean here in the moment
tell me during the game will you tell me
a half time I mean half time is for me
to rest mentally and physically if you
wait till halftime we got a problem
you're not helping me well half
is not like time I don't try to
transition
what was your it's a lot like time yeah
cuz I'm going to the Odell Beckham I
like that I like that no it was [ __ ]
awful yeah I'm trying to help you thank
you um the Odell wearing a three hundred
fifty thousand dollar watch on the field
I got into a few arguments yesterday huh
I want to know what your take is overall
what are you arguing about you like it I
have no problem with it I think that I
think that you could tell who you would
who I would want to hang out with in
life huh based on how you react to this
story well well there's a chance what
happens Adam if a helmet hits it and
then a piece of glass flies up in the
air yeah and then while that's happening
a player yells cuz he just tackled Odell
and then it goes into his facemask and
goes into his eye and cuts his cornea
and he goes blind what then yeah no no
tomorrow
that doesn't concern me okay good so
I'll say this the watch doesn't concern
me to me you find them is it possible to
get hurt by another player wearing a
watch I'm sure that the Odell probably
has more probable likelihood to get hurt
cuz that's the argument that I keep
people yeah I'm not I'm not worried
about the to me it's cut you're not
gonna yeah I'm not worried about the
glass I'm not worried about this I mean
I'm sure that there is some some danger
but if I got pads on and I'm hitting
somebody else the last thing I'm worried
about is that little watch scraping me
I'm trying to knock you I wasn't crazy
this is why it's a non non story for me
if it wasn't Odell nobody cares number
one the other the other part is it's a
fine I see players get fined all the
time visors socks clean wristband cleats
it's a line and if in this is what this
is what I know when the NFL does they
come into your locker room you go out
for warm-ups right you warm up you wear
whatever you want to wear and then you
go back in then the equipment guy comes
to you say okay 36:25 all of these you
guys got to pull your socks up you got
to put your jersey down you got to do
this and if you don't then we're going
to get a penalty or not a penalty you'll
get fine and then as a player you have
to make a decision so I'm absolutely
sure before the game that the uniform
guy came to him and said listen you got
to take this watch
in Odell being him so he said no I'm
gonna do me and I have to believe he's
gonna take the $10 he's getting paid by
this designer whoever there's wash guy
is way more than the defined period now
you think he is getting paid what we
mean I don't know maybe it's just a
casual stuff well well well if the watch
cost three hundred fifty thousand I mean
I would hope to get paid this is my only
thought if it cost 350 and it gets
broken then I got a problem
I'm not worried about someone doing yeah
maybe but that's why he's getting paid
he has to begin paid their jaina
following fine they're paying him to
wear it so I just realized that like I
see guys wearing jewelry all the time
mm-hmm we've seen necklaces we've seen
necklaces gets latched we've seen people
with nice long earrings alvin kamara
wore a very expensive grill during the
game what camara also had a chain on
similar diff and had a whole a whole
piece or the whole piece on it I'm so so
the thing is is they are putting their
own stuff at risk by wearing it but what
I thought about was this I think the the
reason this became a story is because
the price of the watch causes fans to
feel a certain way I mean nobody likes
to know people get very intimidated when
you have something that they can't
afford and you don't care about it like
they would care because to them it's
going wow you're throwing it in my face
I have two arguments
number one O'Dell I don't think hit up a
bunch of media members and said by the
way here's the designer here's how much
it cost can you make sure that you get
photos all right everybody covers Odell
because when you do an article or a post
about Odell it gets clicks Odell is not
asking for coverage the media makes a
ton of money off of covering Odell don't
get it twisted but number two if Kirk
Cousins went out and wore one of those
old Casio watches that have the letters
on it yeah and a calculator huh we would
go that's so awesome
that's so cool Kirk Cousins is wearing a
$30.00 throwback Casio watch because
such a dad oh man yeah but because it's
a 350 thousand dollar watch and that's
more money than some fans will make in a
decade if not longer they take it as an
insult and it becomes a class thing true
thing is is if you compare it to the
percentage of his salary is now it's not
that much no and stop being intimidated
if other people are wealthy I'm not
saying that it's his [ __ ] he could do
whatever he wants you can spend your
money on whatever you want yeah I'm not
a watch guy three hundred fifty thousand
dollars for a watch is crazy to me I
would use that as a down payment on a
beautiful apartment here in New York
yeah but you would have to add something
that in New York
yeah probably which is crazy here that
blue truck whole different world but the
true thing is is if he wants to do it
and it's not gonna hurt anybody
and we're the ones covering them calm
down well you don't get it here he well
here's the I like my hath letes to spend
their money well here he happily it was
Kirk Cousins and lived below their means
I would not care about sports as much I
want my athletes driving Lamborghinis I
want my athletes wearing Tom Ford
I want my athletes popping bottles yes
why because you work your whole life to
live it up right and if nobody's living
it up and we're all living it down then
we're all boring as hell well this is
what I want I want my athletes to have
money after they retired yeah here's
that thing we don't complain about
kickers wearing rings quarterbacks
wearing rings on their fingers
obviously it may be a money thing I
think O'Dell obviously is he's
polarizing in a way right and I think
some people feel that when you wear this
and you just you just buck the system
you're saying it's me and I'm bigger
than the team I think that's what some
people's issues are they're saying hey
you had an issue in New York and it was
it was O'Dell and then the Giants and
you were much bigger than the team which
in reality probably was he was the best
player there he was a he was a highlight
of the team the only between only reason
people were coming to see the team but
some people are saying listen I just
want you to follow the rules I want you
to fall in line
like everyone knows that's the other
people's worry yeah
superstar diva superstar I don't have a
problem I don't care if he wants to pay
the fine
find them that's it to me it's not even
a big deal if he wants to hot you find
them and this is the other side to that
when you continuously break the Uniform
Code they you know you break it a couple
weeks and you keep doing it they say
okay well here's the deal you either
take the watch off or you don't play
that's what happens and you'll get to
that point it will probably this week
you can wear to watch again and win
warm-ups but if you wear it during the
game you're not gonna play I think this
is my personal thought I think Odell is
a showman I think he's an elite athlete
I think he's dynamic I think we get one
of the best receivers in the game I
think if he would have got in the end
zone he had a special little celebration
designed for the watch and you if you
tell me that this designer didn't pay
him they should have because this
wherever this guy is is getting all
types of press that Odell is giving him
an F Odell paid 350 for the watch he
should go to try to get some of that
money back you know what's funny to me
is when I ask people what has Odell done
that's really that bad one of the first
things they always say is well he did
all that stuff with the kicking net I
just want to ask you a question he hit
himself
Odell proposed to the kicking net and
that was seen as a distraction yeah
Antonio Brown
twerked on national television and we
celebrated it as a good dance did we and
I'd ask you celebrated that a lot
no it's everywhere Oh people were like
Antonio Brown he's the best he's so
funny oh my god and I would ask you this
if you had a daughter and one guy was
seen on TV proposing and one dude was
seen on TV twerking here who would we
really have a problem with I'm just
saying it's a double standard
it is a devil first of all mention
everything on TV or not just knowing one
yeah just just I can't work I don't have
that kind of Bob you have you tried I
mean what what tells a percent where do
you try this at at home a house in the
mirror are you looking at yourself deal
with me in my power or loss but I've
seen some Megan D stallion that's like
and she's dropping I really
girl work that you didn't try I want to
try it yeah I mean get comfortable with
yourself right well no I will never be
that comfortable of myself to try you're
telling me you've never tried to tour
can you that's exactly what I'm telling
you've never popped it back done no no
are you serious yeah yeah no listen if
you're afraid that's okay no not only am
I not afraid yeah I just don't want to
do it and I'm gonna tell you this we may
go to a party together in the future
okay let's work at the part listen do
never pull that out ever ever ever never
put on the toilet comfortable huh yeah
because your girlfriend is like go
it's a fiancee figure outside listen
don't don't let me just that up fiance
they're serious about spend a lot of
money to become that congratulations
there don't take that ring off I know
hey hey you tell them you know how it
works you know damn well 33 percent that
westbrook's gonna go home tonight and
look at the baby baby look the so many
of you were coming over Odell Beckham a
[ __ ] I know he's this [ __ ] at me okay
so I did reach out to the 33 percent and
go and I said do you have any questions
for Brian Westbrook although I want them
to get to know you because you're gonna
be here a lot yeah I'll be here every
week so CJ Easterday tweets just
Westbrook have to abide by the left
coast show rules rule number one Aaron
Rodgers is the greatest quarterback
we've ever seen rule number two
Sean McVeigh is our favorite coach in
the NFL and then other rules like beans
not beef if not who is the greatest
quarterback in Brian Westbrook so well
first of all if those are the rules I
didn't get I didn't get yeah I didn't
really tell you people in those rules
because I don't believe any of those
rooms already all at the top Aaron
Rodgers is not the best quarterback
we've ever seen we've ever see their
hammer Patrick mahomes where do you get
this at from my [ __ ] eyeballs Patrick
my house is the best quarterback you've
ever seen you ha and how long have you
seen him play I've seen him play now
have you seen Patrick Meinholz play
without for an extended period of time
without one of the most dynamic
receivers in the game in tyreel no I
haven't no okay well we'll see we'll see
how good he is without that I feel
really good that change I'm not saying
that he won't
who's your vet who's the best
quarterback you've ever seen Tom Brady's
the best quarterback
you ever seen because the best
quarterback wins that's why it's not
Aaron Rodgers the best quarterback makes
the guy's a better quarterback on Monday
night to show Watson or Drew Brees just
answer it truthfully I'm going to show
Watson I think the Shawn Washington
looked the best you got the win drew
Brees
so that means that the shots in that
game it took a loss yeah because that
quarterback wins be a statistic well you
sure will say this that's a mistake
I believe that Tom Brady let me rephrase
the thing Tom Brady is the greatest
quarterback I've ever seen Patrick
mahomes is the most talented quarterback
I've ever scare and that's where I'm
coming from okay is that in Aaron
Rodgers is what and I then the 33% have
told me that Patrick mahomes has not
passed Aaron Rodgers yet in terms of
most talented and I say you know what
I'm down but I think that my Holmes is
close he's ghost he's got he's moving
because I think that there are things
that mahomes can do that Rodgers can't
Aaron Rodgers has wronged Aaron Rodgers
was [ __ ] the greatest thing yeah arm
talent will take the risk of trying to
fit a ball in a window that nobody
should be trying to throw it into you're
right my homes make smarter decisions
than Ron yes he's not gonna make a bunch
of mistakes because Rodgers also has a
freakishly insane touchdown interception
ratio yeah it's insane cuz he's talented
so he's good so who is the most talented
quarterback you've ever seen the most
talented I mean it's just so hard
because Aaron Rodgers has the pedigree
longevity on his side Patrick my whole I
think he's really really excited really
really good you could say Elway you
could say Favre you could say Randall
Cunningham I save dick I think you look
at Marino I think you look at
Elway yep I think those are good
starting points Payton obviously
brain-wise not athletic ability but when
you talk about Aaron Rodgers he can move
a little I know Hilo is a testament you
guys I love Eli I love literally I love
him as a person I think he's a I think
he's cool with me not cool but he's kind
of weird cool but he's a good like
fourth wheel yeah he's like hang out
with Eli tonight like this is a good
night Eli's like it really was yeah
contributions thanks thanks for coming I
appreciate it man keep keep coming keep
coming but thanks for bringing the white
claws I think you start you start the
list at guys that win the Super Bowl
I mean that's what you start at in
obviously I'm talking about Moreno and
he's at the top but he's athletic the
greatest wide receiver of all time
discussion the top three is as always
rice Owens Moss in some order
yeah is the fact that rice won Super
Bowls and they didn't know that really
play on the art and the numbers it's a
numbers but that you just said that
Super Bowls matter four quarters a
different position really because you're
the head of the team you're the
quarterback you're the most important
piece of the team so does that mean that
Trent Dilfer is better than Mario Moreno
no it does not okay but Trent Dilfer had
one of the best defenses that ever
stepped on the field true you ever think
about that just imagine you put that
defense with Patrick mahomes last year
they score 50 points a game in win all
the gadget if you coupled the Ravens
defense this year with Lamar Jackson
don't get out of here kid we're gonna
see another question for you from King
underscore Hermes o4 who was your holy
[ __ ] hit in the NFL that's a great name
by the way
King Hermes my last game it might be
King her mez there you go my last game
in the NFL now I'll tell you about two
hits every I guess hit was your last
game of the NFL I'll tell you three my
rookie year
auntie Reed when we did live here this
was been football was football when we
had to go into trash yeah men were
mainly going to camp you you punch some
ID him on your own team and you fight
and all this other stuff you you versus
Derek Burgess yeah that was not deep
birds as my man he was nasty to I tell
you it was a first team defense versus
second team offense so I'm on a second
team offense with some guys that just
weren't very good at blocking who was
first team Krell buck halter deuce deuce
was the first same endorsee would run
with the first team and then I would run
with the other guys Dorsey Levens or
seal Evans was there I totally forgot
and so I'm running down the sideline
receiver Kester blown I'm just kind of
running just thinking I'm gonna block
blow the whistle yeah and Brian Dawkins
comes out of nowhere in real I don't
have the
I just want to start there I don't have
this is a point of contention between me
and him today I don't have the ball and
he just lays me out and I'm in practice
like what in what type of football is
this did he say anything to you no no no
you just stood over me and looked at me
with the visor and you're like okay okay
okay mr. Dawkins that's it that's we
won't say what the hell no no I'm a
rookie keep your mouth closed and go to
work that's what rookies do just so you
know number two how scary was he he's
nasty and and he's also the guy that
will come up to you after practice say
hey man you're doing a good job and pat
you on the back and this is after he
tries to kill you in practice he's not
friends with you in practice that's
that's the type of guy that he is I I
was listening to Takeo Spikes talk dude
yes you see this deal yeah though I had
no one that posted that spread his
spikes was like yes yes
that's scary if someone comes up to you
yeah what's the scariest Brian Dawkins
transformation that you saw I saw him
suplex
people we played Dallas must have in a
playoff game and so not it wasn't a
playoff game it was a week before the
playoffs we needed to beat Dallas to win
we had to have the Raiders beat somebody
a lot of you got Dallas again the first
week final card in that day I saw this
man that I knew at that point very very
well transformed into someone he had an
interception he had a fumble recovery a
sack he was doing all types of crazy
stuff that I've never seen a safety do
that's the guy that I'm talking but let
me get to my second one Rick you've
remorse Sean Taylor of course obviously
physical six four I remember the first
time I laid eyes on him we're warming up
he's at the other end zone and I don't
know who he is we see him on there like
this defensive end this quote he
standing up underneath the goalposts
with his hands up he's six for Bush and
it looked you're talking about his hair
yeah well at the other things here at
the other hand yeah crazy other hand I'm
like he's touching the goalpost then I
see him running left to right up and
down he's running like a gazelle
I'm like who's who's this kid things
like oh that's I'm thinking it must be a
DN o that Sean Taylor and I'm like what
who the safety like yeah that's him then
you see him in a game and he
downhill and he talks bad to you calls
you all all types of names all oh you
are terrible all anything that you could
think of that you would want you're
nasty
yeah middle linebacker defensive end
safety to say he said that to me during
the game and I promise you after the
game he came up to me what's out
Westbrook what's up man he had a good
game and I just looked at him like I
thought we were actually about to have a
confrontation cuz that's how much [ __ ]
he was talking so bad to me so that that
was number two he'd not be he got me
always the play that he got you we ran a
draw we run the draw everyone's blocked
up linebackers out of the wing and he's
down here just me and him in the hole
and so I'm like you know go time yeah
I'm like all that [ __ ] you were talking
let's go and so I'm gonna give him a
little bit in Rehan when you saw Sean
after singing pregame did you go I'm
gonna Juke him or I'm gonna go head-on
no going head-on was never my game I
didn't think never was my game but every
now when you try to get a shot and so
really my gang was to get him off
balance and then hit him yeah because
when they're all balanced yeah you could
kind of run them over cuz it wasn't my
thing so I tried to make a move and he's
just so long and so physical he just
boom ran into me and naturally you like
oh you took a breath and then he falls
on you like I cracked my ribs cracked my
ribs from the ribs yeah on that play
that wasn't the hardest one my last game
in San Francisco we played the Cardinals
you remember Adrian Wilson Adrian Wilson
is my third favorite safety of all time
so nasty Brian Dawkins and ronnie'll I
love them Adrian Wilson because Wilson
was on the Cardinals for an inordinate
amount of time and was in my mind Sean
Taylor before Sean - yes he was the 64
230 eye that no one else knew and the
reason I loved it was because I played
Madden and I would do a franchise trap
that I was like who's this 97 safeties
we watch him he was incredible so good
so he's about 6-3 6-2 6-3 huge my last
game is so really I knew this was my
last game I knew it before the game I
really pride into it you said you said
last you said on the last episode the
Niner season suck yeah it was bad you
were done I was I was done my last game
I just want to get out of this game
healthy to be able to walk away with my
career be good right so last
Alec Smith throws me like a little swing
pass I'm out in the flat so I'm I'm
turned back to the quarterback looking
at him and I turn back to my left and he
clotheslines me like like literally
clotheslines me 65 yes I land on at this
point Frank Gore is hurt I was probably
the only running back at this and I just
laid on the ground in at that point I
was like yeah football's over for me I
don't want that moment I don't want to
do this anymore
he clothesline the career out of here I
didn't have anything left yeah he wasn't
I mean it was it was it was nasty I
remember I came to the sideline
Tom Rathlin was a coach and all he could
say is are you okay
and I was like no no I'm not okay I
can't breathe probably never answer that
no no no I'm not okay why are we doing
this no don't put me in that position
here's my last game bro don't do that
again Brian Dawkins Sean Taylor and
Adrian Wilson yeah the three big head
three nasty hitters physical nasty and
they all talked trash in a different way
all right one last question that was
good one 70 kilos do you feel swagger
jacked by all these past catching
running backs in today's game hmm
the game has changed and so the only
guys back in the day when I was playing
that were catching pass it was me and
Marshall Faulk literally the only two
and obviously Roger Craig did is he yeah
L LT LT was doing it to Rogers bulbs
Vinny everyone the Eagles of all signs
priest homes pretty son was good
III don't consider priests home it
wasn't a bad he was in the penalty
though yeah LT you can line them up same
thing with more Marshall you put them
you displace them this is the difference
between priests home
you didn't really displace priests only
right and try to get on one on one but
yeah that's what they're doing now I
look at Christian McCaffrey and he's a
wide receiver same thing with with
Canara and but they're really good
running backs too and you know they both
have answered the question can they run
between the tackles and it's it's a
resounding yes yes especially McCaffrey
I'm wondering here's the thing I'm
wondering about chimera and I think he
is talented I know that he can run
between the tackles the load before the
entire season that's I don't watch in
that game and I'm like
I don't even want him back there I don't
think Sean Payton will put him in that I
hope not because my thing is is when you
have latavius Murray and you have Taysom
Hill yeah I'd rather they handle it and
then let camara just start off and flex
outside and go oh you're gonna lie him
back hurt your toast
you got a safety you're toast he's just
so good with the ball I'm so good that's
the that's the dilemma as a hit called
McCaffrey can handle the load I mean
that dude was running over all of the
room he gained some weight he got bigger
and in he's a lot bigger than camara I
feel like well I think I want to say he
was like 210 before when he came in I
feel like he gained seven eight pounds
of muscle this season he looks much more
muscular lament him body 1 205 12
instantly and Camaros ascend at 215 but
that's not the same difference has
changed seeing the camara
but he's so he's so smooth though such a
smooth runner talented makes people miss
he has speed in small spaces that
defenses can't calculate I think I would
take McCaffrey over any other running
back in the NFL right now I like cat
McCaffrey i-i've still would take c'mere
are you it so it's between those two
between those two it's what about say
Kwan oh no you are you tore my past know
this how about already well you would
not no you would not no you wouldn't
if you sauce a qualm with a good team
you'd be like oh wow this is a good team
you think so you think yeah yeah nobody
knows they're everybody else right
Wessex has giant suck right yeah listen
if if you sauce a qualm with a good
offensive line with some people around
and you wouldn't say okay I have a
theory that if you let Bill Belichick
take any player in the NFL from another
team first he would take Karen Donald
but second I think he would take Taysom
Hill I feel like if probably if he could
take any play we use him I think he
would go I could get this kind of like
quarterback running back wide receiver
tight end he could be an h-back that
blocks I could prep I bet you taste some
he'll he already know that he can be a
gunner on special teams
he could probably rush the passer like I
bet you he could be a hell of a third
down Russia he is the bill belly place
safety yeah yeah I think that Belichick
goes I'd be able to get the most out of
taste some he'll like I feel like he
would take Aaron Donald won because I
believe Aaron Donald's
thought about it and then I think he
would go Taysom Hill - he would be a
pretty good theory he would be a bowl
size of the ball type of player
absolutely I'm just thinking about this
Troy Brown played cornerback yep in our
Super Bowl and wide receiver and wide
receiver and punt returner and punt
returner yeah it's what I mean that's
that's who Bella Chad makes me mad
thinking about but that's why I respect
the [ __ ] Ravens too because their
full-back is also their defensive tackle
yeah Patrick I love teams
Sean Payton does that we just talked
about with Taysom Hill where they
they're looking for the best pieces it's
not just their system you know I mean
like they really get it in terms of
games coming up this weekend I'm gonna
be doing the betting show again with
Warren sharp tomorrow that's gonna be a
lot of the gambling but there are a few
games that we kind of circled we
definitely want to talk about yeah let's
do a girl's first Eagles Atlanta yes
Sunday night big injuries from the
Falcons standpoint they lose when their
offensive lineman Kayla McGarry which is
gonna be big their offensive line
already looked a mess Eagles big injury
is Malik Jackson gonna be out for the
year the Lisfranc injury they go and
they sign a team Spence what is your
overall feeling in this because I will
say in Owen one in Atlanta team against
the Philadelphia team that has to come
back from down 17 I don't really see a
huge pass rush from the Eagles right now
which scares me and what the Eagles
secondary just allowed to Washington I
worry about with Matt Ryan and Julio
Jones and Calvin Ridley on the other
side in terms of the Eagles offense I
think the Eagles can put up some points
but how do you see this game kind of
playing out well obviously and I'm gonna
start with Atlanta and I want to just
show you this cuz I looked at this and
I'm like I'm watching the game but it's
not until you actually look at that all
the drives for Atlanta you kind of this
is a theory this is a thought process
here first possession blocked punt
interception punt fumble punt ended path
yeah that's crazy
interception punt find it score a couple
touchdowns they look terrible
first half obviously a couple of
mistakes to me that means if you can
trick them into throwing the ball to the
other team
getting some turnovers which we have it
and now I'm not telling you that the
Eagles can do this that's my fear cuz
that's Minnesota's D Minnesota's defense
is on a different level and I looked
back
Zimmer is three and OH against Matt Ryan
in Minnesota and all the games have been
ugly I think some teams are just better
matchups we know what the Eagles are
gonna do they're gonna play a lot of
[ __ ] man and that's really scary well
they can't play man I know because they
got meat so bad in man but they do I
know but I know I don't know why they
would do they can't do it against this
team they have three good receivers sanu
is really good really is good and
obviously we know Julio you you can keep
her as a baller well here's the other
thing Hooper is a buddy you're right the
Eagles last game every time they blitz
they never got home ever think they have
ended up getting one sack Timmy Jernigan
got that they never got home so they
never got to the quarterback and when
you blitz you put your your secondary in
a compromised position Rasul Douglas got
ran by by some kid that nobody even
knows people know Terry Maclaurin no
they do not stop insulting no they do
not
he has a nickname who what's is it Gary
Terry I didn't make it up that's not his
nickname it is that's Terry Rozier
nickname well this is his no it's not
nobody uses kid nobody no telling what
is gate he played with Hoskins nobody
knew this kid before the game nobody
knows nobody knew but I looked at that
Raskin roster before the game up like
well don't know him don't down know
Trent Williams Oh Terry Lauren yeah well
listen nobody norm nobody expected in
him to have 70 yards nobody nobody so
listen when I see my secondary giving
those types of plays up repeatedly to
your guy Turk Maclaurin that did
everybody knows now he that's receiver
in the game Pro Bowler along the way by
the way exactly but he's gonna get a lot
of options there and and a lot of
targets there Washington but if you're
giving up that and you can't get to the
quarterback with your best guys now
Malik Jackson sout this concerns me
going down to Atlanta season opener home
opener in Atlanta Thunder that's going
to be a problem and if you can't get a
lanta to go on your from their first
half series block punt interception pump
pump pump up hunt fumble then that's
going to be a problem for the Eagles
have traditionally started slow to me
when I watched that football game is 17
zip the only reason I had confidence is
because I'm like I kind of feel like the
rest cos I've played over their head and
they'll never be able to stay in this
office that's it
if Atlanta gets off to 70 nothing I feel
like they can sustain you go to 45
streaming keys gets going at that point
now Julio gets one-on-one and that's
gonna be your problem so as so what's
your gut say about this game my gut
tells me that Atlanta this before before
the season I have circled this game as a
loss for the Eagles oh I didn't see
Atlanta going to get and beat up by the
Vikings right but I also think that the
Eagles this is a trouble spot for the
Eagles I think that this secondary is a
trouble now if you're telling me they
can get three or four sacks then yes
that you get a chance because I would
just say that I thought the Eagles were
gonna get a lot of sex because Trent
Williams wasn't playing for Washington
now good money on the rest of
Washington's offensive line is a lot
better than Atlanta's offensive line
here because Atlanta has has chronically
had issues and now they have injuries I
also think that the defensive
coordinator for Washington is better
than Dan Quinn that's not what Dan Quinn
man the problem is is that he's still
running the Seattle defense and the
Seattle and all of and the it feels like
half the league is playing that defense
and so everyone's gotten used to what
the Seattle beaters are and I'll tell
you who's gonna be a great Seattle
beater DeSean Jackson you think so
oh because going deep over the top it's
it's these routes yeah it's the crossers
where you have that cover three and you
[ __ ] leverage them and it's like okay
you're either taking Matt Collins you're
taking out Sean with the LOB or you're
taking DeSean deep I think this is a
good game for Nelson Aguilar I really do
I think that he could have had a big
game if fold me wince actually throws
him the football when he's wide open
yeah he threw to the Sean let DeSean get
off I understand that this is what I saw
from that offense that played against
the Falcons Kirk Cousins had 98 yards
yeah it's hard to scored 28 points they
ran all over him that means to me
mouse ain't us what are you gonna do
that's a big question might not think
mouse is late well if I'm playing
Atlanta if I'm playing the Chargers I am
running 40 times a game
both of those teams what defense do they
both play the [ __ ] Seattle cover
three press Bay and they both are trying
to be fast up front and don't have big
guys it's Grady Jarrett and a whole lot
of small guys in Atlanta and then in LA
you got Bose and Ingram who are solid
that's right all your defensive tackles
are smallest right the big game the
rematch of the NFC Championship game
Saints Rams it's gonna be in LA so we
won't have a lot of refs jerseys anymore
of the Saints fans coming after the Rams
use you said after watching the Rams
game that the Saints have one guy that
could go really off well we saw the Rams
game last week and it's the Panthers it
gives the Panthers and we just talked
about Christian McCaffrey his ability to
catch the ball out of the backfield do
all the different things he had 128
yards rushing in the 81 yards receiving
I mean he's obviously the best player on
the Panthers at this point but now in my
opinion you play a better version of
Christian McCaffrey and oh by the way
they have some other options other than
Christian McCaffrey and oh by the way
they have a Hall of Fame quarterback
throwing the football so now what
happens now Oh Mike Mike Thomas what you
gonna do against the secondary and they
got some dogs in that secondary but
what's he gonna do we'll find out Eric
Weddle coming off of a concussion
middle linebacker hurt yeah that was my
thing is when I sawed the middle
linebackers out for the Rams against the
Panthers
I went McCaffrey's gonna go off and he
did not only are we getting now the
advantage for the Rams is they have one
extra day to prepare okay we're Saints
played on Monday night okay but it's
Sean Payton has probably been preparing
for the Rams all offseason payback
payback payback and nobody loves payback
more than [ __ ] Sean Payton well I'll
tell you this we saw with the Eagles
last year a couple years ago when they
won a Super Bowl the underdog the chip
on their shoulder the Rams have circled
this game they circled this game in the
locker room last year this is a Saints
give me the Saints yes this is about get
back this is about revenge for them I
think that's a real thing right
absolutely if you if you mess up the
chance and they feel like they got the
opportunity to go to the Super Bowl
stolen from them
if you take that away from a team you
best believe on all season that's all
they're thinking about yeah oh we could
have went to the SU road we would have
beat New England we would have won this
game has been circled for the de saints
all offseason Drew Brees obviously big
time come back in the game on Monday I
think Albert Kummer has a great game
enormous great game enormous Jared cook
to attack the [ __ ] middle of the
field hey put them put the ball in the
middle of the field
drew Brees will find them and I'll tell
you this I you know there were some
questions last year about Drew Brees his
arm and did it get tired down the
stretch it did it did it looked kind of
weak and Paul's shuttering things like
that at early on that season I expect
Drew Brees to go off against weak
defenses we'll see how it goes but I
think Alma cámaras has a great game I
think you put you know Mike Thomas in
another situation to have success this
is going to be a good game I think
there's a running back game for me the
other game that we we wanted to talk
about was Vikings Packers love it
Packers escape last Thursday Aaron
Rodgers with the 150 yard bombed mvs
they're able to go and the Packers
defense was phenomenal now they're
taking on Minnesota yeah who looked
unbelievable the entire game Dalvin cook
alexander madison hell of a duo their
offensive lines seem to be coming
together as you talked about before a
lot of fortuitous plays over that set it
up blocked punt on Atlanta set him up
for a touchdown
a few Matt Ryan interception set them up
Minnesota look like a complete team this
is also the team that hurt Aaron Rodgers
last year so another little revenge
there and it's at Lambeau where do you
kind of how you feel about this one you
know I always side on the team with a
good defense that has the ability to
score the ball on offense and to me the
Vikings has a very good defense they
have a good balance of run with Dabba
cook well i think i think i told you
last week i think he's gonna be a stud
this year he catches a ball well in the
backfield he's great in space and he's
going to get some space because he has
two good targets on the outside he's
done a really good job of getting his
body back into the game after the big
time injury his rookie season
I think Dalvin cook has a great season
period but yeah this the I think it's
the matchup that I love Kevin King je r
Alexander Phelan Diggs what happens in
that I don't know I mean I think listen
this Green Bay defense has improved they
know how to get out their quarterback a
little bit better they have some
quarterbacks that can play they safeties
come down and rock people in the pass
game this is a good matchup this is a
good NFC North matchup in when I look at
these both of these teams I'm saying
okay who has a better quarterback Green
Bay who has a better running back
situation the Vikings who has better
receivers you gotta go Vikings who has a
better defense
I think Vikings so when I look at all
the matches I don't know ones closer I
think so I believe in the Packers
defense so much I think the Packers
right now what have you seen from them
beside the first game of the season I
guess against an average Mitchell try
Biscay I think that Mike Pettine
has has been great with the Packers
defense for the last few years they be
getting better every and I think that
what I saw last Thursday which was the
additions of Preston Smith and za'darius
men including Kenny Clark yeah I thought
Blake Martinez looked like a different
middle linebacker and I also think that
their secondary has a lot of athletes
that are all multi positional I think I
ear Alexander is one of the better young
corners in the league this kids savage
yes and Adrian a MOS both of those guys
can cover a lot of ground and I think
that they can be right where feeling and
digs are gonna be the question that I
have is which is what I think the Bears
wanted to do is if the Vikings go we
want to pound okay which is what they
did against Atlanta which is what Zimmer
wants to do can the Packers and I think
they can I think za'darius and Preston
the two mr. and mr. Smith can set the
edges the question is will the middle
linebackers the safeties be able to
clean everything up well here's the
other question and this is what you go
into the game thinking about okay
well if you stop there pounding do you
need to add a guy to stop the pounding
meaning do you need to go from seven
people in the box to eight meaning your
safeties coming down if you do ru
corners good enough ready to cover the
guys on the outside are they and I think
they are I'll tell you this I think they
they are we'll find out in the game yes
are they good enough to cover the guys
on the outside one on one that's gonna
be a big question and the other part is
that what's gonna happen with Kirk
Cousins
I mean he only the only
you know the only two incompletions last
game but it only had ten passes yeah is
he ready to take that next step so this
is this we're gonna find out I would say
right now I'm gonna dive in deeper I'll
give my official prediction on the
podcast tomorrow
come on but I want to get my prediction
for Thursday Night Football because this
podcast comes out on Thursday mornings
it is gonna be bucks at Panthers I just
looked it up Jameis Winston in his last
three games against Carolina is one and
two in his last through in his the three
times he's played at Carolina he's one
and two he's put up 1917 and and ten
also remember we chronically see home
defenses dominate on Thursday Night
Football okay there's not enough time
for the big game plans to come together
so we and the team that usually prevails
is if the home team has a good defense
they do I do not know what the line is
right now but I think that the Panthers
are gonna win this one pretty strong I
think that loss is upsetting to them I
think that they are a much more
disciplined team even though they were a
little bit erratic then Jameis Winston
and Tampa Bay and I would I would go
with the Panthers as I look at the line
here's the deal if Jameis Winston will
decide nope it's not gonna happen if he
can decide that he's gonna take the fall
to the guys and a half the guys in the
same uniform is him if he'll make that
it's not bro when he when are we gonna
give up when are we gonna go I thought
Bruce Arians was gonna fix him nope
I thought Bruce Arians was a quarterback
whisperer that was gonna put him in a
position to these facts that you've
whispered or peyton manning a carson
palmer account and ben roethlisberger
and andrew luck different level okay
okay that's my point
well Jameis is what he's number one
overall number two whatever you want
number one yeah well I mean he had some
but he has a skillset we know that you
got to be able to get something out of
this kid and obviously they're trying to
give him a chance he did not look good
last week three interceptions miss
Russell's number one too disappointing
yeah disappoint you went in the third
round yeah and you
better than all the running backs I went
ahead and sure what I wish I would have
got some first round money I wish I
would just as a side note but anyway
just as an aside I would like that was
there a first round running back to went
your year that you look at I played in
the senior bowl with Jonathan Wells and
I think he went well maybe late fruity
Wells no Jonathan Wells he went to O
state okay I think what second round
first round and I was like mmm I got
this guy come on bro I played in an
all-star game with him he was big a
bunch of yards but I'm like the skillset
didn't I didn't think unless you're
gonna get 30 carries a game yeah there's
just not many tinker's doing that
different game but I'll tell you this
Ronald Jones look good look better than
I thought he was gonna look even though
we know he has some talent I don't know
about this offense I still think they
have some you know I think goblin is a
good player okay not elite but okay yeah
I think this office needs some work
it's it disappoints me that the
progression I'm talking about my
quarterback Jameis isn't getting better
no that disappoints me because you had
all offseason the coach just didn't get
there but and he's still deciding to
throw the ball to the other team that's
gonna be a problems gonna be a problem
in this game because the Carolina
Panthers and Robert bear I will get
after him yeah well I think I don't care
if the line if you can get it at six and
a half you take that I like Carolina at
six and a half I think that Sheamus is
gonna throw you into some situations
where I think he's gonna force it and I
think Carolina's losing that game is
gonna come back angry and and look could
girly had some success but that's Todd
Gurley and that's Sean McVeigh yeah and
different world and I watch Tampa Bay OJ
Howard has some fumbles Jameis through a
pick six at the end that was one of the
most embarrassing things I've seen and I
know that it's a rivalry game and it's a
little bit tight but I like Carolina I
want to wrap up the pot I just want to
go out really quick we didn't talk about
a B and I think we are gonna play a
little bit of wait-and-see right now I
think that there's a lot of questions
emerging around the alleged lawsuit
right now the lawsuit has been filed
where Antonio Brown is being accused of
rape from a former trainer a lot of
informations coming out right now though
that are raising a lot of questions I
think we both agree that
if he did this disgusting yeah he should
be punished anybody breed yeah he's good
anyone any any show host is saying
exactly what I'm saying right yeah if he
did it he should be condemned it
shouldn't play at the same point we kind
of need this to play out we need more
information
and we're gonna see how the Patriots and
Bill Belichick handle it I would be
surprised if you played on Sunday
against Miami but we're gonna kind of
wait and see on the details but it is
interesting that it's coming out you
know before the first week that he could
play and we're gonna wait and see but
it's man it's more noise I mean again I
tell you this all the time in an NFL
team the enemy is noise and I'm talking
about the media problems issues that's
the one thing that no coach in the NFL
once we talk about Odell Beckham jr.
just noise you lost the game noise
Antonio Brown this entire situation
noise I we have to wait for more
information I as a coach and a teammate
the last thing that you want to deal
with going into a game week throughout
the season is noise this is just more
noise yeah unfortunately and it's sad
it's sad on both sides is sad we'll see
how it comes out I really hope it didn't
[ __ ] happen cuz if it did your
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] there's no doubt
about yeah sam says uh I enjoyed this
week though hey man it was fun I'm ready
to see what happens with the Baltimore a
well they're gonna see we've been
attacking me on Twitter
really I hate him he's from Maryland he
should support them we'll see we'll see
how good Lamar Jackson oh he's gonna be
[ __ ] amazing
he's gonna be amazing why because
Patrick Peterson suspended and the
Cardinals secondary stakes he's gonna
put up big numbers again and I'm going
like a genius for B West
I am the lef koe man hit us up on social
what's your social again 36 well I got a
brand new website didn't get me tell you
about
WWWE Westbrook calm brand new website
all the information on there the most
important thing is about the Brian
Westbrook foundation ok what do you work
on we're talking about empowering our
youth down in my horse farm empowering
our youth teaching them all different
types of skills to be successful in our
world that's what everybody wants hope
our kid with horses
absolutely horses we talking about all
different
types of trades mechanics carpentry
electricity we want to teach our kids
some things that they may not be getting
from schools right now we want to help
our kids be successful that's why you're
good [ __ ] amen enjoy the games
this weekend make sure you download the
next podcast Warren Sharpe making all
the bets
see you later homies
[Music]